hey guys so I don't know if you know or
not but when I was younger I wanted to
be an astronaut and now that I'm older
and not as young as I used to be what I
actually wanted to be an astronaut I
actually still want to be an astronaut
but I'm realizing now that it's pretty
much impossible what is possible is
floating in zero gravity and not too
long ago I actually got a chance to
float in zero gravity and a huge thank
you to Kaboodle's for making it happen
because I took these guys with me I
packed up my spacesuit my makeup and all
of my gadgets and here I go I went to
space sort of I've been sitting here
thinking about gravity around the
universe reaching out and grabbing me
it's like everything's pulling me back
to you I've been wondering if it's
unreality or if somebody up there is
glad to be it's like everything's
pulling me back to you
excited
look at the difference yes have you seen
front
we floating weightless here in a matter
of probably five seconds are you guys
don't need to see it
I just got to believe it I know can't
believe it soon cuz it's true I've been
staring at the night sky wondering
what's really keeping me under if it's
like everything's falling me back to you
that's five
don't need to see it alone I just got to
believe and you know I know that you
can't believe that - because it's true
I could just close my eyes and deny and
nexi skies
but you everywhere think about gravity I
reaching out and grabbing me and pulling
me back to you think about gravity just
Region IV me me back
me
you that's gravity
back
thank you so much to the moodle's and
sponsoring this room I had a fantastic
time and thank you to all of you million
subscribers as well my million
subscriber video I love you okay I have
to go if you guys like the caboodles
that you saw in my video just click the
special link in the description of this
video that'll take you to the contest
page then just click like follow the
directions on their Facebook page and be
one of the 20 random people to win all
three Kaboodle's good luck hope you guys
enjoyed my zero gravity video I had such
an amazing time and thank you to all of
you guys who really made this possible
you've been so supportive over the years
and you guys made my dream come true of
becoming an astronaut almost an
astronaut but it's close enough anyways
I've had a few poor videos over here for
you to check out this one right here is
the floating wood iPhone video and this
right here is some behind-the-scenes
videos and some of the clips on there
actually have the real audio of the
clips that you just saw in the past
video and let me tell you what it's
pretty funny a huge thank you again to
you guys another thank you chicka
boodles who sponsored this troupe and
made it all happen for me and you guys
are awesome be sure to check them out on
Facebook and also last but not least
Jess Smith whose song I used zero
gravity check him out also links all
below and you know what he's guy that
made the ask IJ intro are you kidding me
how awesome is that so awesome I love
you guys Wow talk to you soon bye